okay so how do we find these stable
marriages well there's a procedure for
doing it which is kind of elegantly
described as a day-by-day mating ritual
that the boys and the girls cooperate in
so let's see what happens on the first
day on the morning of the first day each
boy looks at his list of girls and picks
the one that he likes the best that at
the top of his list and he goes off and
serenades her or proposes to her so here
we have Billy Bob and Brad proposing to
Angelina that means that on the first
day Angelina was at the top of both
Brad's list and Billy Bob's list and
they're both going to be proposing and
asking if she's willing to marry them
well in the afternoon each girl rejects
all but her favorite suitor so in this
case Angelina likes Brad best of all so
she says to everybody else if you're not
Brad take a hike and that's what happens
at that stage and then in the evening
here we look at rejected by her boy
Billy Bob a boy who's rejected crosses
off the girl who rejected him so Billy
Bob is gonna cross Angelina off his list
and then the whole ritual is going to
repeat starting the next morning except
that now Billy Bob will have a different
woman at the top of his list because
Angelina has gone forever
okay this mating ritual continues until
nothing changes and that's gonna happen
exactly when each girl has it most one
suitor because if she has more than one
suitor she's going to reject the less
favorite ones so that is the definition
of the stopping condition and on that
day by definition no girl can have more
than one suitor so she will marry the
one suitor she has and that's the
definition of the marriages that result
if and when the mating ritual stops and
we claim that they are going to be
stable marriages now if we think about
this process it's really a state machine
in fact if you think about it what the
states are is the is the set of girls on
the boys list on any given
morning and then those states evolved to
a new list after the crossing out
happens on the next morning so this is
kind of a memorable way to tell a story
about the transitions of a state machine
and we can bring our state machine
concepts to bear so the first thing we
want to prove is that this state machine
terminates that is to say there exists a
wedding day then we want to prove that
this state machine is partially correct
and what that means that when the
machine stops everyone is married and
that the marriages are stable so that's
our task
well termination is easy because if you
look at the state the state is the boys'
lists on a given morning and things
evolve because boys get rejected and
they cross girls off the list so what
that means if we take the total number
of names remaining on the boys lists on
any given morning that is a strictly
decreasing a non-negative integer valued
variable so by the well ordering
principle that's strictly decreasing
well ordered on derive area Bowl will
reach a minimum value and by definition
that's when the algorithm has to stop
because it's strictly increasing so it
can't move once it's reached its minimum
so there's a wedding thing all right so
now let's examine correctness of this
procedure and figure out what's supposed
to happen on the wedding day we want to
show that everybody's married and that
the marriages are stable and in order to
do that we're going to look at some more
derived variables and in variant that
explains why the mating ritual works
so the first remark is that the girls
improve day by day or at least they
don't get any worse namely a girl's
favorite tomorrow will be at least as
desirable to her as her favorite today
that's for any given day if you look at
a girl's favorite on this day and if
there is it tomorrow then her favorite
tomorrow is going to be at least as good
as the one she has and why is that well
because today is favorite
we'll keep serenading her until he gets
rejected and he only gets rejected when
the girl that he's serenading gets yet a
better suitor and so the girls are
always gonna win probe we can
reformulate this in in state machine
language by saying that the rank of a
girl's favorite where she rates the boy
that's serenading her on her own list of
preferences is a weakly increasing
variable it never gets any worse from
one day to the next
by the same reasoning or similar
reasoning a boys favorite tomorrow is
gonna be no better than today is it
might be worse and it's so it's no more
the woman then you're gonna say tomorrow
is no more desirable to him than today
is basically because he worked straight
down his list if he hasn't been rejected
he'll keep serenading the same woman
tomorrow if he has been rejected then
he's gonna be working on somebody lower
on his list that's less desirable so
again the rank of a girl on a boy that a
boy serenades is a weekly decreasing
derive variable of this process and
these observations lead us to an
invariant that holds for the mating
ritual and the invariant is that if you
look at any girl gee and if there's a
boy B and G is not on B's list that is G
must have been crossed off by B at some
point then the invariant is that the
girl G has a favorite that is better
than than B and the reason is that again
when G rejected B she had a better
suitor than B and her suitors keep
getting better by the weekly increasing
property of her suitors and therefore
she's gonna have a suitor that she likes
and we better than B whose list she's
not on this holds for all Gees and B's
and that is an invariant from one day to
the next so let's look at what happens
on the wedding day and use the invariant
to prove that everybody's married and
that stability holds so the first remark
is that each girl has it
most one suitor and we've observed that
spy definition of a wedding day and now
what we want to prove is that um uh each
boy gets married well what's going on
with a boy a boy is either married
because he's serenading the top woman on
his list or maybe all the other women on
his list have been crossed off then he's
not Sarah nany s serenading anybody so
that's the only way that he could be not
married now the reason that this is the
case is that there's no bigamy here so
um boys serenade only one girl at a time
so if a boy is married there's only one
possible woman that he can be married to
and a woman is only married to one
possible boy so let's now put these
facts together and argue that everybody
is married on the wedding day and the
proof is by contradiction suppose
there's some point B that's not married
well that happens exactly when his list
is empty otherwise he'd be serenading
somebody and may it be married to her
but if his list is empty by the
invariant every girl has a suitor that
she likes better than B which means
she's gonna be married to somebody that
she likes better than B every girl's
married but there are the same number of
boys and girls so in fact given that
there's no bigamy all the boys have to
be married to and that settles that one
so the next crucial property that we're
interested in is stability that in fact
this set of marriages which must come
into being on the wedding day are all
stable and the argument for stability
has two cases both of them trivial and
that follow immediately from the
invariant um first of all let's look at
an arbitrary boy Bob I claim that he
won't be in a rogue couple with case one
any girl G that's on his final list
because if a girl is on his final list
then he's already married to the best of
them he marries the girl at the top of
his list so he's not going to be tempted
to switch to be part of a rogue couple
with some girl that's uh still on
list k-stew is he's not gonna be in a
rogue couple with a girl that's not on
his list because by the invariant she's
married to somebody she likes better
than him so there's no available girl
either way for Bob to be in a rogue
couple with Bob of courses an arbitrary
boy and therefore no boy is in a rogue
couple and indeed there are no lobe
couples